paid by it apartment under indoors a
certain car no would you like to be yes
we're clones it's not see this to my
dildo you know like what is your deal I
want to but it has to be the car that I
want yeah but what if I say okay what's
a car that you don't like I don't like
the Prius I'll give you ten million
dollars to drive a Prius in the
commercial the window rolls down yeah
ten million dollars you know well there
I go by Weber car I do like I feel about
a bit of twelve of them we're gonna
write that into your contract one day a
month you have to drive around a Prius
with the windows down going I am all
right on there I just don't like the car
but I will put it Michael for ten
million dollars I'll paint my name on it
right we'll do a roll down window and go
hi I'm Martellus Bennett I don't like
the Prius but they gave me ten million
dollars to say I do
alright I gotta get that music - can you
be bought from you set your hip-hop
bebop I hate it alright here we go
hi my name is Ellis and I'm driving this
Prius look at my wings finning look at
my wrist spin I'm driving the wind for
10 mil I'm driving drunk driving the
wind for 10 mil huh ten million dollars
to drive a Prius you would drive one two